depending on activity level the heart
beats about 60 to 100 times per minute
it may be higher during exercise or
lower at rest
a normal heart rate and rhythm ensures
the delivery of oxygen-rich blood to all
of the body's organs such as the brain
and lungs
a group of cells in the heart called the
cardiac conduction system uses
electrical impulses to control the speed
and rhythm of each heartbeat
an abnormal heart rate or rhythm called
an arrhythmia occurs when there's a
problem with the heart's conduction
system
tachycardia is a type of arrhythmia
where the heart beats too fast
fibrillation is a type of arrhythmia
where the heart beats irregularly and
may be too fast
for certain types of arrhythmias a
catheter ablation procedure may be
necessary to stop the heart tissue from
causing the arrhythmia
after numbing a small area in the groin
with a needle
the doctor will insert a short hollow
tube called a catheter sheath into the
femoral vein
next a long flexible tube called a
catheter will be inserted through the
sheath
the doctor will guide the catheter to
the heart through a blood vessel that
goes to the heart called the inferior
vena cava
the location and progress of the
catheter will be monitored
when the catheter reaches the heart the
doctor will guide it to the area that is
causing the arrhythmia
the doctor will find the problem areas
using a 3d map of the electrical
activity of the patient's heart
the tip of the catheter will emit either
hot energy
or cold energy to ablate the tissue in
this area
ablation makes the treated area stop
working
for an atrial arrhythmia
a doctor will ablate the atrial tissue
causing it
if the affected tissues are small
well-defined areas the procedure is
called focal ablation
or if the affected tissues are larger
areas with more complex rhythm
disturbances the doctor may perform a
procedure called ablation remodeling
both types of ablation restore normal
electrical impulses and prevent an
arrhythmia from happening
if the cause of the arrhythmia is in the
ventricle
the doctor can do either focal ablation
or ablation remodeling to treat more
complex arrhythmias of the ventricle